das ist richtig hart zwei herzen egal
wir können es nicht geben so alter ist
er gut ist der gut der ist echt nicht
schlecht
hallo leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren folge handicap games
spielen
das handicap dass ich mir ausgelassen
ich mir selbst einige bosque hat weil
ich letztes den kommentar nicht viel
gefunden habe an dieser stelle nochmal
der aufruf sei teure handy kommentaren
wirklich viele gebiete tolle spannende
und damit wir hier weiter klasse sachen
um können sie sich das heutige handicap
lautet schwerter sind verboten
und die muss heute so weit wie games
spielen ohne schwerter beziehungsweise
theoretisch kam eine runde entfernt
je nachdem wie viel läuft vielleicht ist
es auch möglich das was man isst aber
wird es richtig schwer weil wenn man
keine angst hat keine angst hat darf man
nicht reiten es sei denn man kauft sich
ein aus dreieich die relativ selten bei
weitem nicht so häufig wie doch ich
nehme das mit arbeitskampf perfekt aber
ich darf damit nicht kämpfen das ist
mein erster eindruck
hochnäsige ca wenn nur ein einziges mal
mit dem den klicks nehmen täglich mit
naja man ja das war wichtig das war
richtig wichtig wenn du noch 22 nur noch
zwei teams und stock gehört das ist echt
gut nächste
wie ist es keine schwere nicht also ein
bogen ist und schwert oder ob man die
kommentare beim bogen erschwert dass
genau das ein kurzes fertig zu machen
weil draußen person redet mit der wir
vielleicht in einem freundschaftlichen
verhältnis stehen weiß natürlich nie so
genannt ist es auch ein motor
foto war für mich wie ein vater peter
koren
da ist der erste oder ob es wird es
unser erstes kind laufe nicht weg wir
hatten es nicht gesehen als sie gegen
die wand den preis als nicht so gefallen
gut gegen die wand macht da bringt mir
leider überhaupt nichts simon epping
aber habe ich echt glück dass ein
spitzer bekommen hat muss ich sagen und
welche am tresen leiter des bisher mit
einer holzschnitte
die holztreppen genau und da ich mal
richtig mein ding auspacken müssen oder
deinen richtig was du sagst es nicht
hätte ist nicht meine videos im future
wieder ab in den klassen kannst du
wachst oder vom 2 juni werden die sehr
gut die ist sehr gut und die nehmen wir
uns wo wir können es noch eisenachs
machen den gleisen gesehen
wer das gesagt wenn ihr die drei als
werden von den drei siege aus richtern
achtung auf dem ds das ist die shelter
doch eltern hacks der sein baumeister
nicht nächste hektar vielleicht wissen
wir genügt ja ich bin's ich bin so wie
wir es jetzt kommunizieren kennst du ja
nein nein du bist lassen
man ist knapp an meine fresse
meine fresse oh mein gott das war die
hunde hier bereits verkaufen können aber
ich bin kein depp brad pitt kopf blöd
kopf sowie nimmt sich dem schreiben
nicht immer mit karstadt leute genau
wissen genau die werte für die stehe
backstage und lexa bing.com durchschnitt
zu mir passen zu mir es macht auch die
angst der stellt dann muss sie noch mit
ihnen kommt genau genau da kommt einer
gestern in was für einem team
das bakom dekra der musste ich da musste
ich da und seien und er ist richter
anders verhält muss tina land behalten
all diesen tarifen heiltränke hat der
junge ist übelst die heiklen gab es ein
richtig spannender fight alter kommt wie
vor macht auch immer schlafen
anzugreifen einheit herzen gehen auch
drauf erzählt ein alter bestimmt
die lakers waren sechs räte den doch
warum hinter den nicht was okay das ist
okay
denn guillou ist mir das ist richtig hat
zwei herzen egal wir können jetzt
entwickeln jetzt nicht geben malta ist
sehr gut ich sehr gut
der ist echt nicht schlecht wir können
wir können schaffen wir können schaffen
wir können schaffen
folgt der uns von glaubt gerade über
schiffen wieder ins wasser links
befindet erfolgt und nicht mal was aber
anders verlaufen das land ins wasser
haben wir noch ein schwert das du
findest du deinen blocken falls ja ok
wichtig wichtig alte was das für eine
runde
die vereine richtig harten weiter junge
ein kind an dem hobby ein jüngeres
sterben alter gibt dem dsm doch zurück
zu schildern er musste ja auf dauer muss
auftauchen
bin ich wirklich langsam
jetzt hat minister sind
im boot
richtig gut der hat aber auch barocke st
oder müsste seinen jetzt ins wasser
angestellten mit den weg abschneiden sie
das wort das war die kasse runde
zuerst hatte 84 138 kg kann sein kanal
geht weiter direkt wurden
ivan z
jetzt möchte
mein herz an herz an herz dich
veröffentlicht wird ist was zählt auch
dass der mann nicht schlecht aber nicht
schlecht jetzt habe ich immer wieder zu
viel zeit gegeben
schade
die die auf jeden fall leute wie gesagt
was machen
ich bin sein
a relaxed roll geräts fricka latte dann
haut drei leute lassen positiven da ihr
wisst bescheid ein ganz wichtig hatte
handicaps in die kommentare
dann werden die nächste wollen dann
kommen wie gesagt der name will auch
genannt wird er es möchte also falls ihr
mal in so einem video auftauchte von
nickel gutes handicap aus schreibt das
in die kommentare an sich noch nicht
wieder ab 31